[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 au 71e jours de la
guerre en ukraine la russie poursuit son
offensive à l'est et ces frappes un peu
partout dans le pays à marioupol port
stratégique du sud est assiégée depuis
des semaines la russie assure que des
couloirs humanitaires fonctionne autour
de lusine asos talent la dernière poche
de résistance ukrainienne mario paul où
un défilé militaire russe serait en
préparation pour le 9 mai le 9 mai c'est
une date symbolique puisque la russie
commémorent ce jour là la victoire de
l'union soviétique contre l'allemagne
nazie des célébrations sont aussi
prévues comme chaque année à à moscou
sur la place rouge alors évacuer les
civils d'azov thales une manière pour
moscou d'en finir plus vite afin de
pouvoir décréter une victoire totale
d'ici lundi même si le kremlin a écarté
ces rumeurs le président russe pour est
il utilisé cette date du 9 mai pour
déclarer la guerre à l'ukraine est ainsi
décrété la mobilisation générale alors
qu'il n'a obtenu aucune victoire
éclatante depuis le début de ce conflit
le 24 février dernier face à une armée
ukrainienne de plus en plus armés par
les occidentaux vladimir poutine serait
t-il capable de déclencher une attaque
nucléaire on va en débattre ce soir avec
nos invités l'ena volochine journaliste
france24 spécialiste de la russie
bonsoir elena merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous jean paul palomeros également à mes
côtés ancien chef d'état major de
l'armée de l'air ancien commandant
suprême des forces alliées de l'otan
bonsoir julien theron enseignant à
sciences po spécialiste des conflits et
de sécurité internationale coauteur de
poutine la stratégie du désordre bonsoir
merci également d'être sur ce plateau et
puis antoine à rakowski historien
directeur de recherche au collège des
bernardins auteur notamment de voyage de
saint pétersbourg à moscou anatomie de
l'âme russe merci à tous les quatre
d'être sur ce plateau j'aimerais d'abord
qu'on fasse un point sur la situation
sur le terrain qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement ce moment à marioupol autour
de cette usine asos talent ou moscou je
le disais en introduction à décréter un
cessez le feu unilatéral de trois jours
mais kiev accuse de son côté la russie
de ne pas du tout le respecte et on va
voir ça avec david gilbert on en reparle
juste après
les combats se sont intensifiés ce jeudi
à marioupol l'usinage of talent à siéger
dernière poche de résistance ukrainienne
est toujours la cible d'intenses
bombardements
la veille la russie a annoncé un nouveau
cessez le feu de trois jours pour
permettre de nouvelles évacuations de
civils encore abritées dans les sous
sols du complexe métallurgique
l'armée ukrainienne et les membres du
régime nationaliste azoff qui se trouve
à l'intérieur affirme que rien n'a
changé
de violents combats sanglants se
poursuivent
les défenseurs de la ville se bat seul
depuis 71 jours contre les force
écrasante de l'ennemi une fois de plus
les russes n'ont pas respecté leur
promesse d'une trêve et n'ont pas permis
l'évacuation des civils qui continuent
de se protéger des bombardements dans le
sous-sol de lusine de son côté moscou
dément vivement tout assaut sur l' usine
notre président et commandant suprême le
président poutine a donné l'ordre
publiquement de ne pas lancer l'assaut
sur l'usinage opstal
aucun autre ordre n'a été donné
la date du 9 mai prochain et les
commémorations de la victoire soviétique
sur l'allemagne nazie semble en tout cas
être une date butoir pour l'admirent
poutine qui pourrait à ce moment-là
proclamer une nouvelle victoire
militaire
dans cette optique une escalade
permettant la prise de l'usinage of
talent et donc de la totalité de la
ville portuaire stratégique de marioupol
n'est pas à exclure
julien theron ce qui est cette situation
très confuse à marioupol c'est quoi
c'est le résultat d'une guerre de
communication aujourd'hui entre moscou
et kiev c'est une situation compliquée
parce que le président poutine n'aurait
même pas besoin de prendre cette usine
pour déclarer victoire et l'a mis sous
clé le système informationnel en russie
suffisamment pour pouvoir annoncer une
victoire d'ailleurs cet effet dans
plusieurs théâtres d'opérations
s'étaient fait aussi en syrie d'ailleurs
plusieurs fois donc ils peuvent tout à
fait se permettent de dire on a gagné à
mario paul on a
déjà dit absolument donc dire que la
raison pour laquelle ils s'abstiennent
de cet assaut final et je crois que
c'est très important de toujours
analyser les discours et d'ischia pas
d'assaut final en réalité il l'assaut
n'a jamais cessé sur l' usine l'usiné
bombardés quotidiennement enfin je veux
dire il est très clair que à chaque fois
qu'ils aient une déclaration c'est notre
responsabilité de journalistes de
chercheurs d'analystes à chaque fois de
bien analyser cette chose là et dire que
si si il ya toujours un assaut c'est
juste qu'ils ne peuvent pas descendre
dans les souterrains parce que du point
de vue des pertes en soldats russes qui
sont déjà extrêmement lourde c'est
extrêmement risqué voilà une volochine
l'armée russe est toujours prête à
assurer l'évacuation des civils d'azov
talent c'est ce que vient de déclarer le
kremlin c'est ce qu'aurait dit vladimir
poutine
pourquoi là tout d'un coup vladimir
poutine se soucie du sort de ces civils
dans cette usine il serait encore des
centaines bloqués alors le plus à
l'observation de ces plus de deux mois
de conflit me conforte dans ma certitude
que j'avais pourtant au départ une
supposition que la dîmière poutine s'en
soucierait mais que vladimir poutine ne
se soucie absolument pas du sort des
civils alors effectivement
officiellement l'armée russe le général
cône a chaîne kof a déclaré trois jours
de cessez-le-feu absolue pour permettre
l'évacuation des civils mais il faut
dire que le même général konaté en cov
et son état-major publie des communiqués
quotidiens où il affirme que la russie a
un objectif purement humanitaire en
ukraine et que son seul but c'est de
respecter le droit humanitaire
international de préserver les civils
l'infrastructure de l'ukraine ça ce sont
les termes officiels donc il faut bien
comprendre que lorsqu'ils disent qu'on
arrête les combats pour permettre aux
civils d'évacuer et qu'ensuite ils
disent que le cessez-le-feu n'a pas
fonctionné c'est toujours la faute des
ukrainiens illya hamac de mon souvenir
et de cette observation aucun couloir
humanitaire annoncée par la russie
depuis le début du conflit qui a
fonctionné alors que la russie n'a de
cesse de dire que tous cas à chaque fois
ces couloirs et met à mal il ya quand
même quelques civils qui ont été évacués
oui l'internet joueurs de centaines et
100 civils ans et ça continue alors il y
a oui mais après il y a surtout l'effet
d'annoncé c'est à dire que ces civils il
faut comprendre le cauchemar qu'ils sont
en train de vivre depuis le début de
l'ue de l'assaut des obstacles pourquoi
il ya autant de monde là parce que
marioupol étant encerclé pilonné est
prise en méthode chaudron comme andy par
les russes et bien c'est ces kilomètres
et kilomètres de souterrains c'était le
seul abri pour ceux qui n'ont pas quitté
la ville qui ont pu se réfugier là avec
les combattants pour essayer de survivre
tout simplement donc ils sont assiégées
on entendu vladimir poutine encore une
fois dans un effet d'annonce dire et
d'ailleurs la russie dément depuis le
début la présence même de civils au sein
de cette usine asos talent il narrait il
n'a cessé de dire dans leur communiqué
le ministère russe de la défense soit
les combattants retranchés dans l'usiné
asos talent et les est soi-disant les
civils d'après les affirmations de
l'armée ukrainienne donc ça c'est aussi
une hypothèse qui a toujours été mise en
doute par les russes ensuite vladimir
poutine a dit s'il y avait des civils
dans cette usine eh bien on arrête
l'assaut mais on fait en sorte
ok cette usine il l'a dit à sergueï
choïgou enfin assis en face de lui vous
bloquer cette usine de façon à ce qu'une
mouche ne puisse pas volé donc ça
c'était les termes employés est en
réalité comme le disait julien à
l'instant finalement le la saône n'a
jamais cessé mais on est dans cette
rhétorique dans cette propagande au jour
le jour qui est de dire que la russie
veut préserver les civils qui est de
dire que la russie est dans une
opération humanitaire et que son but
c'est de détruire les nazis les
nationalismes et de préserver les civils
en réalité sont en train de vivre un
cauchemar absolu parce qu'ils sont
bloqués dans ces souterrains sans
approvisionnement sans vivre sans
médicaments sans possibilité d'en sortir
est apparemment avec des dizaines de
personnes qui sont tout simplement à
l'agonie et il ya des enfants là antoine
jackowski
la situation très difficile de ces
civils dans cette usine est bien de
l'entendre avec elena volochine et on a
donc l'impression là que tout d'un coup
le régime de vladimir poutine prend
beaucoup plus de pincettes avec ces
civils car il ya tout une guerre
d'information sur ce qui se passe asos
talent et c'est surtout on a
l'impression beaucoup plus de pincettes
après les massacres de boudhha qui ont
eu un retentissement international
pourquoi ça
non on est dans dans une logique de
propagande c'est à dire que tout le
monde comprend bien qu on se prépare
pour le 9 mai pour célébrer la victoire
et la question c'est de de la célébrer
le mieux possible aujourd'hui kiriyenko
était à marioupol kirienko sergueï
kirienko ancien premier ministre à
l'époque de eltsine qui
décide de qui a été nommé responsable
pour le kremlin de la république
autoproclamée de donetsk de lougansk et
qui inaugure aujourd'hui un monument
voilà dédié à cette victoire de
libération une grand mère qui a sorti un
drapeau rouge et donc ça a été filmé
aujourd'hui avec la symbolique
soviétique donc le 9 mai victoire sur
les nazis symbolique soviétique c'est ça
qui est mis en en place et quand on
regarde attentivement dans d'une part on
se rend compte que c'est de la
propagande pure par rapport à cette
grand mère parce qu' elle n'est pas du
tout venu accueillir
l'armée russe puisque sa propre maison a
été bombardée par l'armée russe donc
c'est quelqu'un qu'il était contre
l'armée russe mais qui est récupéré par
la propagande voilà une image et l'autre
élément de la propagande qui est utilisé
aujourd'hui c'est de dire et vous l'avez
dit vous-même dans votre reportage que
c'était une victoire le 9 mai de l'union
soviétique sur le nazisme alors que la
victoire sur le nazisme
les 8 et 9 mai
c'est une victoire des 55 pays uni dans
cette alliance qui a permis de vaincre
le nazisme les russes présentent
aujourd'hui cette victoire comme si
c'était là leur meneur unis maman
uniquement et dont il ya plus du tout
cette alliance des pays alliés des
américains etc et donc ça leur permet de
dire aujourd'hui nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir lutter contre le monde entier et
regardez ce qui s'est passé à ramstein
regardez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec cette conférence de donateurs nous
sommes contre le monde entier ça c'est
de la propagande
à nouveau c'est ça qui se passe voilà
quand quant aux images sur les civils
bien entendu qu'ils vont montrer des
images les plus montrant leur visage le
plus l'humanitaire possible mais pour
moi kirienko qui est devenu donc
maintenant ce responsable du kremlin sur
place pour moi c'est un nouvel adolf
eichmann cdh man c'est lui qui a envoyé
des gens rencontrent concentration
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale qui
était un haut fonctionnaire nazi qui a
appliqué les ordres voilà sans aucune
indépendance et là on sait très bien que
un grand nombre d'ukrainiens qu'ils
veulent sortir de l'enfer sont envoyées
en russie en sibérie dans des camps de
concentration terrible donc voilà c'est
ça qu'il faut prendre conscience pour
prendre distance par rapport au discours
de la propagande soviétique juste en
deux mots pour rejoindre ce que vous
disiez pour vous dire à quel point la
russie réécrit aujourd'hui l'histoire
c'est parce que on a changé un petit peu
de discours dans la propagande on ne dit
pas aujourd'hui on dit aujourd'hui que
l'occident est en guerre contre la
russie est passée plus seulement
l'ukraine et pour faire le parallèle les
officiels russes disent aussi que
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale comme
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale alors
que tout le monde entier était en guerre
contre l'union soviétique voyez alors
qu'en fait il y avait une alliance entre
l'urss et les occidentaux pour vaincre
hitler mais ils vont jusqu à réécrire
l'histoire dans ce sens là en disant qu'
aujourd'hui comme à l'époque c'est là
finalement le monde entier qui s'est
rebellé contre la russie il ya eu une
photo il n'ya pas longtemps publiant des
draps et des drapeaux nazis du minuscule
parti nazi américain dans les années 30
pour explique quand ça que les états
unis étaient alliés aux nazis pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale jean paul
palomeros un dernier mot sur ce qui se
passe à marioupol avant de repartir sur
sur ces célébrations du 9 mai est-ce que
là ce qui est en train de se passer ces
évacuations de civils l'onu a dit que
des cars étaient en route pour continuer
les évacuations de cette usine on a
parlé de vladimir poutine
qui a dit que voilà c'est quoi ces
couloirs humanitaires étaient en place
est-ce que c'est pas une manière
finalement pour moscou d'en finir plus
rapidement avec les soldats ukrainiens
qui sont sur place car si on fait partir
les civils
ça y est ils peuvent dire appuiera
finalement plus grand monde dans cette
chose je suis ni par penser que la
lumière poutine et c'est ses assistants
si je peux dire met volontairement cette
ville au supplice parce que d'abord il
ya une histoire en 2014 cette ville
n'est pas tombé dans lorsqu'il ya eu la
première le premier conflit ukrainien
cette ville n'est pas tombée dans
l'escarcelle russe elle s'est défendue
s'est battue vaillamment et elle a sauvé
en quelque sorte sa peau
ça c'est un premier élément il veut
faire un bon sens de marioupol un
exemple mais d'ailleurs ce qui se passe
à marioupol sous une autre échelle se
passe dans d'autres dans notre affaire
aussi de ses soldats ukrainien des
martyrs alors c'est là que tu veux en
venir et c'est soleil craignant ils se
battront maintenant jusqu'au bout on
entendu on l'a vu
ils sont là pour défendre leur pays ils
sont là pour défendre la liberté et sont
là pour défendre l'ukraine indépendante
oui ce sera sans doute des martyrs mais
si vous voulez je pense puisqu'on arrive
aux neuf même moi je pratiquement une
proposition à faire c'est que ce 9 mai
ils deviennent le jour de mémoire de
marie paule de ses habitants de ses
combattants tour un peu contrecarré ses
trois grandes effectivement qui vient
d'être parfaitement décrite dans notre
collègue
il faut pas qu'on se laisse intimité à
mon avis par cette propagande ne faut
pas non plus qu'on tombe dans l'erreur
de penser qu'il ya un équilibre entre la
propagande la bonne et la mauvaise
propagande entre les deux camps on n'est
pas du tout dans le même genre ça veut
pas dire que les ukrainiens n'essaye pas
d'utiliser l'information mais ça ça fait
partie de la guerre mais pas pour
détourner l'histoire si vous voulez donc
il faut que marié vols restent dans les
mémoires absolument parce que peut-être
que dans quelques mois dans quelques
années le rare ici qui nous conduira
concurrents ne s'est pas à une analyse
beaucoup plus philosophique beaucoup
plus intelligent des choses en ils ont
finalement non il faut pas que ça se
produise mario matt aut se préparerait
donc un défilé pour pour le 9 mars et
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirment les
services
secrets ukrainiens ce sera important
pour moscou si ça a vraiment lieu à
marioupol ce serait tout un symbole mais
un symbole terrible parce que c'est une
ville détruite à 90% avec dans l'idée
que c'est absolument ridicule à une
ville vidée de ses habitants
complètement détruite et en plus on
murmure qu'ils veulent faire défiler les
prisonniers donc avec une volonté
d'humilier la nation ukrainienne donc ça
ça va ça va jouer contre encore une fois
là à la réputation de la russie qui a
déjà qui est déjà très basse
je pense que c'est un effondrement
civilisationnel absolue moi j'ai assisté
à la première parade de la victoire le 9
mai 2014 en crimée annexée c'est là où
vladimir poutine est entré dans la baie
de sébastopol cette ville qui à l'époque
elle même soumise à cette propagande qui
disait que des nazis avaient pris le
pouvoir à maidan qu'ils allaient venir
massacrer les populations russophones de
crime et on voyait à l'époque et on
comprenait pas ce qui se passait parce
que tout ça se mettait seulement en
place mais nous journalistes sur place à
l'époque on voyait les habitants locaux
former des brigades d'autodéfense les
l'armée russe sans insigne encerclé les
bases de l'armée ukrainienne des
mercenaires qui encerclent et russes qui
encerclaient les bâtiments officiels et
des cosaques et on revenait de maidan où
finalement on a assisté un soulèvement
du peuple pro occidental pour contre la
corruption pour la liberté pour intégrer
l'europe soulèvement qui avait
finalement effectivement fini par être
extrêmement violent mais la propagande
russe de l'autre côté et c'est pal sur
les chaînes de télévision russes
raconter aux populations de crime et que
des nazis avaient pris le pouvoir à kiev
et allait venir les massacres et donc on
voyait se mettre en place cette réalité
parallèle et on voit je crois ce sont
louis ces images de crimée en ce moment
louis justement voilà donc lcd et
vladimir poutine était entré dans la
rade de sébastopol pendant pendant cette
parade et à ce moment là si vous voulez
il y avait une euphorie absolut
plusieurs régions plusieurs villes de
russie avaient afflué dans cette petite
ville de sébastopol y avait tout s'était
bien passé plus de place et s'est bien
passé il ya une forêt de la population
qui étaient galvanisés par cette
propagande et qui croyait à ce mythe
dans lequel qu'on l'avait plongé comme
quoi la ville avait de nouveau triomphé
des nazis alors qu'on n'a jamais vu un
seul nazis apparaître en crimée mais
enfin ce n'est pas grave on est on est
dans une réelle parallèle depuis 2014 en
russie est aujourd'hui pourquoi je dis
que c'est un effondrement parce que
marioupol on est on à une parade sur des
os sur des ruines
c'est ça va être une une parade de mort
où on va quand même entériné et andy qui
je ménage il bougeait desquels ils ont
bougé des cadavres justin mais c'est
terrible c'est terrible ça dépasse
l'entendement si vous voulez mais le
message sera le même ce sera que ici
ville martyre on a la grande armée russe
a triomphé des nazis et je vous assure
que c'est exactement comme ça qu'ils
vont écrire cette histoire et il patine
sur le terrain ukrainien vladimir
poutine parce que ça a commencé le 24
février dernier cette offensive
il veut donner quelque chose à l'opinion
publique russe julien t on l'imaginerait
libertines ce 9 mai justement date
symbolique oui on peut quasiment
considéré que ce défilé va être aussi
morbide que l'ena l'indiqué parce que
précisément ils ont mis plus de deux
mois à prendre une ville comme mario
paul qui étaient encadrés par les forces
russes qui est une ville de taille quand
même tout à fait raisonnable avec toute
la puissance russe qui a été déployé
comme le racontent les survivants d'un
obstacle vient du maire la mer par la
turn mais la tendance à ça mais autant
de temps ils sont retranchés dans une
usine non mais déjà ils n'ont pas été
pendant deux mois retranchés dans une
usine c'est que les résistants et
l'armée ukrainienne ont résisté aux
troupes aux troupes aux troupes russes
donc c'est juste dû à de nombreux
problèmes de l'armée russe non sur
lesquels on peut revenir mais c'est
juste pour dire que ça s'est il se
raccroche à ça au kremlin parce qu'ils
n'ont que ça sur le capacitaire enfin
très sincèrement j'étudie et très
précisément l'avancée des troupes
l'intégralité des problèmes de l'armée
russe de l'armée ukrainienne aussi les
comment dire les livraisons en armes
occidentales et très franchement mais
même aujourd'hui alors on dit que il
avance un peu dans des bases mais déjà
c'est extrêmement limité par rapport aux
moyens qui ont été mis en place mais il
ya des contre offensives au nord vers
artif et au super ersonne des
contre-offensives ukrainienne et il ya
aussi une guerre de partisans vers
milito pâle dans le sud de l'ukraine
dont je veux dire ça se passe pas du
tout comme il l'avait prévu en termes
capacitaire ils ont des problèmes encore
considérable ils ont dû déployer ce
qu'on appelle la rose marque dia qui est
censé garder l'ordre poutine east en
russie ils ont déployé dans ces zones là
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que
pour eux maintenant c'est la russie et
comme
on l'indiquait tout à l'heure 7 cette
grand-mère qui porte un drapeau rouge
c'est le drapeau de l'union soviétique
pour eux un grand mélange sémantique en
fait c'est honnêtement on a vraiment du
mal même dans le mille de la recherche a
essayé de comprendre les espèces de
schémas intellectuelle qu'ils essaient
de créer entre totalitarisme libéral
européen une cro nazisme enfin il ya des
choses vraiment qu'ils sont vraiment
très très complexe a même
échafaudé donc ils essayent juste
d'expliquer en fait c'est à nous on est
de retour mais la réalité capacitaire
sur le terrain la réalité opérationnelle
et franchement franchement enfin je
pense que vous pourrez en acte et on a
vraiment complètement surestimé les
capacités de l'armée russe qui
finalement s'est aussi retirée de la
région de kiev ils ont pas du tout
réussi à attendre leur premier objectif
jean paul palomeros justement est-ce que
à l'occasion de ce 9 mai on peut
imaginer que la russie va déclarer ça y
est officiellement la guerre à l'ukraine
et faire une mobilisation générale parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une opération
spéciale a officiellement ce genre
je ne sais pas mais j'en vois pas
l'intérêt je n'en vois pas l'intérêt ce
qu'ils auraient besoin de davantage de
d'abord la terrière il va lancer ils ont
lancé des opérations de guerre ils ont
lancé un blocus c'est un acte de guerre
etc etc donc la guerre de facto il la
mène et il faut bien qu'on fasse
comprendre au monde et pas uniquement à
l'occident qu'il mène une guerre contre
l'ukraine sais c'est pas un message qui
bat partout dans le monde sa deuxième
élément il si vous voulez pour pour
réussir une campagne militaire il ya
trois ingrédients en un sens il ya la
stratégie d'abord sans stratégie vous
aller nulle part quelles que soient vos
capacités qu'il sera t il au départ bah
ils ont une stratégie du mal à
comprendre c'est expliquer la stratégie
du commander en anglais de wishful
thinking c'est ça va se passer comme ça
qu'on va rentrer et l'ukraine basse va
se démanteler bassam eux démembré tel un
château de cartes elles des dominos
parce que on aura frappé le pouvoir et
parce qu'on aura frappé ils ont nié en
quelque sorte aussi la tentation
hésitation et j'en suis sûr tous deux
comme s'était dit parfaitement ils ont
surestimé leurs capacités parce qu'il
s'était jamais lancé évidemment
peut-être quand une armée dans le monde
d'ailleurs ne serait aujourd'hui capable
de lancer une opération aussi complète
il faut ça posait pas de question et et
donc il faut une stratégie qui n'étaient
pas là et qui n'est toujours pas claire
qui n'est toujours pas clair ils ont
changé plusieurs fois d'objets compas on
pensait qu'ils allaient se concentrer
mais non ils continuent alors c'est
normal ils vont frapper des objectifs
c'est peut-être le moins c'est encore le
plus compréhensible et continue à
frapper à l'ouest et oui ça se
concentrent qui s'attaque au point de
gravité au centre de gravité c'est je
dirais presque la moindre des choses
malheureusement une stratégie des
capacités militaires dont on voit
qu'elles sont défaillantes il a quand
même là à peu près la moitié des
missiles aérien qui est qu'il fonctionne
pas enfin je donne un chiffre à vue de
nez mais c'est pas très loin d'autres
d'être ça et puis il faut surtout la
volonté des hommes et d'éventuellement
des femmes de se battre or celle là on
la sent pas bien quand vous parlez de
conscription en fait la conscription ya
pas il a pour l'instant il n'a pas
mobilisé particulièrement il a fait
fonctionner la conscription comme elle
fonctionne en temps normal mais ça veut
pas dire pour ça que vous appelez sont
ravis parce que je pense que maintenant
ils doivent commencer à comprendre ce
qu'ils vont vraiment faire en ukraine
contrairement à ce que ce qui était le
cas au début donc ce sens la volonté
avec une mauvaise stratégie et des
capacités défaillante vous n'allez pas
très loin cqfd
et puis surtout comment dire ils ont
perdu d'après les ukrainiens plus de
vingt mille soldats
et les ukrainiens conçu quand même de
près depuis 8 ans ont tendance à ne pas
sûr exagéré leurs chiffres donc ils en
sont même à 24000 donc disons
avec of havas coffre il dit plus de plus
de 24000 et multiplie par 3 pour le
nombre de blessés 6 me voilà donc c'est
plus que la guerre d'afghanistan
en dix ans la guerre d'afghanistan en
dix ans en dix ans 79 89 15 mille morts
donc ça veut dire c'est dramatique en
réalité pour l'armée russe et donc c'est
ça c'est ça que on va essayer de
masquer pendant le le 9 mai mais en
réalité ça ne trompe personne si les
médias sont à ce point bloqué en russie
c'est précisément parce qu'une
information est totalement vide la
formation est verrouillée mais quand
vous faites des micro trottoirs comme ça
peut encore se faire de façon
indépendante j'en ai vu il ya encore
aujourd'hui à rostov la population est
contre cette guerre voyez
en tout cas serrée microsoft j'ai pu
voir
sinon sinon on ne on e on ne verrouille
ray pas à ce point d'information alors
je suis d'accord qu'il ya un bon tiers
de la population qui est favorable au
conflit ceux qui ont été pendant des
années qui ont donc dans le cerveau a
été complètement vidanger mais
en tout cas d'après ce que me disent
mais mes correspondants ça n'est qu' un
tiers de la population les autres choix
ont peur soissons contre soit 120 voilà
c'est ça qui se passe et on assiste
aujourd'hui au départ des élites à
vitesse grand v alors nous on a fait
justement un micro trottoir quand je dis
on c'est même moi mes collègues et moi
sur place à distance dans le centre de
moscou donc ce n'est pas en région
on avait sur vingt-et-une personnes
interrogées on en avait 8 qui était pour
l'opération spéciale 7 qui était contre
la guerre et 6 qui n'ont pas répondu je
m'explique les tout le monde est contre
la guerre le de ses adversaires dont
surtout les russes sont oui exactement
mais tous les russes sont contre la
guerre vous ne trouverez pas un russe
même qui soutien à l'opération spéciale
de vladimir poutine qui vous dira qu'il
est pour la guerre parce que la guerre
c'est mal c'est là où des gens meurent
et c'est là où des enfants meurent et
c'est là où des babouchkas pleurs et
c'est là où des gens souffrent vous ne
trouverez pas un russe censé qui va vous
dire qu'il est pour la guerre enfin non
j'exagère vous en trouverez mais c'est
vrai que la plupart ils sont contre sauf
que pour eux ce n'est pas une guerre et
ils ne l'ont dit textuellement lors de
ce micro trottoir et des gv et on parle
d'opérations spéciales oui c'est pas
pour rien que vladimir poutine a
interdit de parler de guerre comme
d'ailleurs il interdit de parler de paix
puisque il n'y a pas ce que tous les
gens qui sortent pour la paix se font
tout autant à réprimer que tous ceux qui
sont contre la guerre puisque s'il n'y a
pas de guerre il n'y a pas à dire qu'on
est pour la paix si on est contre
l'armée russe tout ça pour vous dire
c'est pour ça que je n'exclus pas là la
déclaration de guerre le 9 mai si jamais
ils avaient besoin de mobiliser parce
qu'il ne peut pas mobiliser lorsqu'il en
train de mener une opération spéciale
alors que les russes croient sincèrement
que la russie est en train de mener une
opération spéciale n'est pas une guerre
il ne voit pas les images de
bombardements des villes russes il ne
voit pas les ukrainiennes ils sont en
train de voir des bourses à passer à ce
qui s'est passé à abuja
bien entendu parler bien qu'on leur en
parlerait il ne vous croirez pas et ils
vous attaquerez en disant que vous êtes
en train de mener une guerre
informationnelle contre eux et que vous
voulez part cela détruire la russie
parce que le pendant de la propagande ce
n'est pas seulement de faire circuler un
message c'est aussi de dire que ce en
face menthe et donc cette opération
spéciale c'est censé être quelque chose
de propre c'est pour ça que le langage
de l'armée russe cd frappe toujours ils
utilisent les mêmes mots la propagande
dansant dans deux selon le manuel
d'utilisation de la propagande c'est de
marteler toujours les mêmes termes pour
être convaincant pour que ça impacte les
esprits donc c'est de dire des frappes
ultra ciblée avec des armes de poing à
guidage ces images satellites de frappe
seulement contre l'infrastructure
ukrainienne on ne bombarde jamais d et
c'est donc ces sales opérations
spéciales c'est la différence avec une
guerre c'est qu'on ne détruit pas
l'infrastructure civile et on ne
massacre pas laisser ma compagne est
donc si jamais juste pour terminer sur
lequel quelle pourrait être la
rhétorique c'est de dire puisque
l'occident armes et ukrainiens ça c'est
nous qui le comprenant mais la russie
dit puisque l'occident armes les
ukrainiens l'occident est en guerre
contre la russie est donc aujourd'hui
nous n'avons plus le choix que de
déclarer la guerre et c'est là où la
guerre pourrait lui permettre de mener
cette mobilisation nécessaire pour
avancer et il pourrait justifier si ici
des images parviennent à la population
russe également exactement on a vu hier
volet 1 lors des répétitions de cette
cérémonie du 9 mai à moscou on a vu
voler un avion un peu spécial un
iliouchine
80 voler au dessus de moscou est-ce
qu'il faut il y voir le signe d'une
menace de la part de vladimir poutine
menace
pour les occidentaux n'ont alors là pour
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
jean paul paloméros que c'est que c'est
faux dit il faut dissiper tous les
doutes vous remercie de poser la
question en fait c'est un avion qui doit
assurer la permanence du commandement de
l'autorité supérieure les américains ont
un air force one et ce sont des avions
qui sont équipés pour que président en
l'occurrence
le la des meilleures poutines puisse
effectivement en cas de menace en cas de
montée en puissance en cas de tout ce
qu'on veut
puisque quelque part s'extraire dans une
certaine mesure de 2,2 du conflit et
continuer à assurer la continuité de
l'exercice du pouvoir et donc ces avions
sont équipés pour recevoir des
communications et sur un certain nombre
de caractéristiques très particulières
qui ont fondé avions aussi très coûteux
et c'est ce qu'ils disent qu'est ce
qu'il montre qu est-ce qui monte par la
lima toute façon il y aura pas de
rupture dans la north a pas de solution
de continuité dans le pouvoir on a les
moyens et puis c'est un gros avion ça
des plus gros avion du monde il y voir
une menace nucléaire dont il faut pas à
mon avis il faut dissocier ça c'est une
démonstration alors après le nucléaire
c'est un sujet en soi d'accord le fait
que ce type d'outil d'avion de
plateformes de commandement existe c'est
effectivement un certain nombre qui
l'avait pas volé cet avion dans le ciel
de moscou dont avoir des problèmes de
maintenance
jeunes en fait ça fait partie de la
démonstration d'ensemble en dix ans le
pouvoir et et robuste il sera toujours
aux commandes et puis si on a poussé les
opérations à l'extrême moi je serai
toujours le maître de la russie ne vous
en faites pas à quoi c'est pour
tranquilliser les esprits puis pour
montrer aussi une certaine forme de de
capacité avec la taille de cet avion et
l'envergure mais l'avion lui-même n'a
pas de capacité particulière si ce n'est
celle de pouvoir exercer le commandement
dans des périodes
de rupture si je peux dire la russie qui
a aussi mené des frappes hier des essais
à kaliningrad
ces simulations des simulations
émulation informatique voilà et ça est
ce que on peut y voir encore là une
menace
c'est fait pour terroriser kaliningrad
c'est à une heure et entre deux pays de
l'union européenne louis puis c'est ça
ça peut berlin paris londres peuvent
être visés le but c'est d'être c'est de
terroriser mais là ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que par rapport à ce
type de rationalité complètement
apocalyptique le la réponse est la
fermeté c'est d'ailleurs ce qui avait
fait le général le ministre des affaires
étrangères français le drian ya quelques
semaines en disant nous aussi on a une
capacité non seulement de résister mais
aussi d'utiliser des frappes tactiques
nucléaires il faut être très ferme
d'abord parce que c'est ça qui
impressionne poutine on l'a vu en 2015
je crois quand il y avait eu cette
affaire de l'avion qui avait été
descendu par erdogan à la frontière
syrienne savait immédiatement calmé
cesser ses incursions des avions russes
en turquie et en syrie et puis ça donne
une cohérence ça donne une cohérence
quand quand quand l'occident dit on n'a
pas peur parce qu'on est des démocraties
et qu'on aide et qu'on défend le droit
international c'est ça aussi qui permet
de mobiliser l'opinion publique
occidentale en disant ce qui nous unit
est bien plus important que ce qui nous
divise à savoir le respect du droit et
et et d'un pays comme l'ukraine et puis
le troisième avantage je pense de la
fermeté par rapport à cette guerre
hybride qui vise à nous terroriser ses
de dissuader d'autres pays comme la
chine en particulier de trop se
rapprocher de la russie si la chine voit
que l'occident est terrorisée par ça
la chine dont on sait qu'elle a signé
une alliance avec la russie avant la
guerre pourrait et qui regarde de très
près ce qui se passe en ukraine
mais bien sûr bien sûr alors que la
seaal inverse il ya plus de 50 pays à
ramstein plus de 40 pays à rammstein qui
décident de s'unir pour soutenir
l'ukraine pour dire voilà on a mis 33
milliards de dollars sur sur le plateau
est aujourd'hui les européens qui disent
à peu près la même chose puisque si la
france mais 2 milliards on espère qu'on
pourra à 27 à atteindre des sommes
importantes eh bien ça par contre ça
peut dissuader la chine de trop se
rapprocher de ceux de ce discours
apocalyptiques de la russie je viens
theron est ce qu'on doit craindre les
menaces de vladimir poutine les menaces
nucléaires depuis le début de ce conflit
les brandit il y à cette date du 9 mai
qui arrivent sur le terrain on en a
parlé
c'est pas vraiment des succès un pur
pour moscou ce qu'il ya un vrai risque
alors
il ya plusieurs éléments premièrement
les menaces il faut les prendre au
sérieux il faut toujours les prendre au
sérieux on les a pris extrêmement à la
légère en traitant les américains
d'alarmiste pendant des mois avant que
assez bizarrement après deux invasions
de l'ukraine et avoir massé 190000
troupes autour du pays étonnant et nous
avoir dit qu'il allait y aller si on lui
répondait pas à ses caprices il y aller
c'était assez étonnant mais alors je
vais pour être tout à fait honnête mais
j'étais à kiev en janvier près justement
parce que j'étais assez convaincu qu'il
désirait et même à kiev certains
interlocuteurs parfois penser qu'il
n'irait pas donc mais enfin quand même
on a traité ça vraiment très très
légèrement à peu près dans tous les
domaines qui touchent qui touche au
conflit en france particulièrement en
france et en allemagne
donc il faut les prendre au sérieux il
faut toujours prendre au sérieux ce qui
nous dit et quand il nous parle de
nucléaire il faut le pronom seraient
connus parle de troisième guerre
mondiale il faut le prendre au sérieux
d'ailleurs comme ça a été dit la guerre
c'est la guerre conventionnelle qu'on
avait oubliées d'ailleurs depuis huit
ans qu'on pensait qu'ils faisaient que
de l'hybride c'est à dire la guerre sans
violence s'y emploie et emploie des
enfin en tout cas un peu détournée
donc il en a profité il envoyait une
guerre conventionnelle mais il peut
aussi revenir sur les greens dont je
veux dire là ils sont un petit peu
occupé comme vous le savez mais enfin je
veux dire ça veut pas dire du tout que
c'est terminé au contraire la télévision
russe passe son temps à expliquer que la
russie est en guerre contre l'occident
c'est pas nouveau cela fait huit ans
qu'il explique qu' il ya une guerre une
troisième guerre mondiale qui est déjà
en cours ça c'est important et elle
évoque aussi souvent la vie au public
assis on est déjà dans une troisième
guerre mondiale la télévision russe qui
est aussi évoque les différents
scénarios d'une guerre nucléaire combien
de secondes ça prendrait le nouveau
missile sarnaks prendrait pour frapper
londres berlin ou paris paribas mais ça
c'est quoi c'est pour préparer
l'opinion publique sur russe sur l'armée
nationale mais là sur la menace
nucléaire il ya deux éléments qui me
semble important et il ya effectivement
ce que nous disent les renseignements
militaires américains notamment qui se
sont avéré assez fiable c'est à dire que
non la menace n'est pas réel dans le
sens où il n'y a pas de préparation
actuelle de frappe nucléaire et à côté
de ça il ya ce qu'on peut considérer
comme une menace politique de guerre
nucléaire et qui existent aussi est ce
qu'on a pris comme de l'irrationalité
chez blatter coutume n'est pas de
l'irrationalité du tout il est
parfaitement rationnel c'est juste qu'il
fonctionne pas exactement selon notre
même
rationalité et on a confondu rahi
rationalité extrémisme et pour lui
effectivement il mène toute une série de
guerres y mène une guerre contre
l'occident une guerre contre les pays de
l'est une guerre contre l'ukraine une
guerre aussi contre son propre peuple ce
qui lui interdit les médias est de
savoir ce qui se passe une guerre aussi
au sein du pouvoir russe et il n'a pas
beaucoup de cartes effectivement il ya
la conscription mais la conscription
c'est compliqué il ya une loi qui dit
qu'il faut au moins quatre mois
d'entraînement avant d'envoyer des
soldats russes au 1er avril y avait déjà
une conscription mais ça veut dire qu'il
serait pas disponible avant la fin de
l'été c'est pas très pratique et puis
c'est pas sûr que les russes les jeunes
russes suivent et l'autre arme c'est
ce qu'on appelle le crb n c'est à dire
du chimiques radiologiques biologiques
ou nucléaires alors évidemment même au
sein du régime on le sert notamment au
sein de l'armée il ya assez peu
d'appétence pour ce genre d'outil mais
voilà il a quand même peu d'outils et il
est vraiment dans ce qu'on appelle le
haut du spectre à dire que sa menace
politique évolue dans ces éléments là
pour d'abord influencé sa population
deuxièmement nous faire peur mais il a
assez peu d'options comme moi je suis
russe donc j'ai par défaut peur de
vladimir poutine et j'avais que dix ans
dans la réalité parallèle donc je prends
l'irrationnel au sérieux je voudrais
rappeler deux épisodes et ça ce sont des
faits qui nous permettent d'avoir des
repères c'est que au tout début de la
guerre en ukraine vladimir poutine a dit
puisque les occidentaux ont une
rhétorique agressive
puisqu'on est menacée et bien je mets
mes forces stratégiques donc les forces
nucléaires en ordre de bataille qu'est
ce que cela signifie cela signifie
qu'elles sont toujours de toute façon
prête à intervenir les forces
stratégiques par définition parce
qu'elle a sur l'existence et à la
sécurité de l'état russe mais là ça veut
dire que tout tout tout l'arsenal tous
les le tout l'arsenal au sol les sous
marins nucléaires et les bombardiers
sont prêts à décoller son dans les
chansons dans l'océan pacifique ils sont
prêts et les missiles qu'il porte porte
déjà les cibles qu'il devrait atteindre
en cas de déclenchement de la guerre
nucléaire ça c'est ce que ça veut dire
être en ordre de bataille je parle sous
votre contrôle
juste pour terminer que ça c'était le
premier épisode est le deuxième épisode
c'est que la semaine dernière à saint
pétersbourg l'admirent poutine et vous
lui disiez il faut prendre il faut
écouter ce qu'il dit et le prendre au
sérieux parce qu'il a proféré des
menaces directes à destination de
l'occident en dix ans nous avons des
armes comme vous comme nous n'allons pas
vous en nous en vente et vous n'imaginez
même pas ce que la puissance qu'elles
ont et nous nous n'hésiterons pas à les
utiliser les décisions ont été prises et
ça c'était menace des menaces en lan à
l'encontre des occidentaux en leur
disant si vous mêler de ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine or les livraisons
d'armes qui ont été annoncées les armes
lourdes les 20 milliards dead américaine
à l'ukraine c'est exactement le scénario
selon lequel dans le selon lequel dans
le discours de vladimir poutine la
russie porterait une menace
existentielle serait menacée de façon
existentielle par l'occident et ses skis
dans la doctrine nucléaire russe qui
présuppose que si l'existence de la
russie et menacés seraient frappés par
par l'occident et bien cela autorise la
russie à utiliser l'armé nucléaire et
comme on est dans une réalité parallèle
où finalement les faits réels n'ont pas
d'importance mais c'est simplement le
récit qui en est fait par l'afp des
rations de russie et par le kremlin qui
compte dans pas seulement pour l'opinion
publique mais même dans ces actions
finalement à justifier ses actions cela
permet d'agir de la façon dont il le
veut finalement et donc moi c'est ça qui
est vraiment aujourd'hui m'inquiète il
ya une vraie on va écouter tout de suite
la réaction je vous laisse réagir après
jean paul palomeros on va écouter la
réaction du président américain joe
biden justement il ya quelques jours à
ces menaces russe d'avoir recours aux
armes nucléaires
non une chipie personne ne devrait faire
des commentaires sur l'utilisation
d'armes nucléaires ou la possibilité d'y
recourir c'est irresponsable
voilà il responsable c'est c'est la
réaction de joe biden jean paul
palomeros vouliez réagir oui je voudrais
réagir tout tout ce qui a été dit
parfaitement exact et les sous-estimer
la menace et la première faute de
n'importe quelle commande qu'ils soient
militaires ou politiques chefs
militaires donc en 2014 lorsqu'il ya eu
ce premier conflit je vais vous dire que
j'étais à l'époque donc à la tête du
commandement la transformation l'otan on
a pris ça très au sérieux ce qu'est ce
qu'il nous a permis d'ailleurs de
présenter au chef d'état à l'époque on
s'en souviendra un plan de marche pour
restaurer les capacités de l'alliance
des 28 pays à l'époque qui sont 30
maintenant est d'atteindre les 2 les
fameux 2% du pib ça vient exactement de
ce constat et on a réussi à les
convaincre de faire sa première et en
deuxième élément l'otan est une alliance
nucléaire et trois pays de l'otan sont
des alliances nucléaire sont des pays
autonome et strates et qui ont une
stratégie de dissuasion
là où le monde a changé c'est que
pendant la guerre froide il y avait des
arsenaux colossaux des milliers de têtes
mais il ya une certaine
logique et une certaine volonté de
stabiliser cette escalade et
progressivement des outils se sont mis
en en ont été mis en oeuvre des traités
pour réduire le risque entre jeu
dirigeants
responsable aujourd'hui le risque de
lasser l'irresponsabilité
tous les traités ont été foulés aux
pieds il compris celui des armements à
portée intermédiaire qui portait
justement sur ces armements la crise des
piercings il faut se souvenir de ça donc
pendant la guerre froide on avait les
outils on avait une architecture de
sécurité qui certes a tenu par la menace
par la menace d'une destruction mutuelle
assurée mais ça a tenu maintenant
comment on fait pour restaurer d'abord
il faut montrer sa force et je pense que
si poutine a bien peur de quelque chose
c'est l'otan il ne cesse d'en parler
donc si il en a peur de cette unité et
il essaiera de l'attaqué et notre part
de ces de ses capacités nucléaires mais
l'occident nous nous n'avons pas besoin
de montrer nos capacités nous en sommes
nous sommes conscients qu'elles sont là
et je peux vous dire que ce sont prêtes
et on a pris un but serait immédiate la
réponse de l'otan mais si c'est même pas
une question
mais je pense quand même qu'on a on a
intérêt quand même à le dire à la nation
russe parce que le problème dans cette
dissymétrie diana propagande et au fait
que les médias soient bloqués en russie
c'est que les russes sont comme pris par
une sorte de fantôme est d'ailleurs
poutine lui-même l'a dit on est entré en
guerre parce qu'on n'avait pas le choix
c'est le fantôme qui nous a conduits
voilà et donc les russes ont du coup
cette logique il va y avoir une guerre
nucléaire la propagande nous en parle
tout le temps
donc pour arrêter cette logique
apocalyptique je pense que c'est
important de s'adresser non pas
simplement aux élites mais de ça de
s'adresser aussi à la nation russe
attention ce qui se passe n'est pas un
jeu vidéo vous serez également les
victimes d'une réponse immédiate
des pays alliés à ramstein contre
l'invasion de la russie donc et et je
pense qu'il ya une façon graduée de
réagir et l'une des propositions qui
pourraient être faites en tout cas je
viens d'écrire un article là dessus
c'est de poser la question de la place
de la russie au sein des nations unies
au même titre que la russie a été exclu
de l'assemblée parlementaire du conseil
de l'europe
pourquoi la russie fait toujours partie
des nations unies alors qu elle bombarde
kiev lorsqu antonio guterres yes je
viens viens à kiev quelle humilité
nations unies or les nations unies et je
reviens là dessus parce qu'on parle de
la deuxième guerre mondiale les nations
unies sont nés pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale roosevelt en 42 a
commencé à parler d'une alliance des
nations unies qui va devenir en 45 la
charte des nations unies en a 500 de san
francisco et cette charte l'article 1er
de cette charte dit nous nous unissons
pour la paix pour la sauvegarde de la
paix et nous prendrons toutes les
décisions pour que la paix soit
maintenue si aujourd'hui alors qu'on
voit que l'un des membres du conseil de
sécurité fait tout contre la paix soit
l'onu veut survivre à la cette nouvelle
guerre qui est en train de se produire
et éviter le sort de la sdn finalement
de ce qui s'est passé la société des
nations qui a disparu dans les années 30
à cause de hitler soit l'onu veut rester
une institution qui maintient le droit
international et à ce moment là elle
explique à la russie qu'elle n'a plus sa
place ni au conseil de sécurité ni même
au sein de l'assemblée des nations unies
au moins pour un temps
soit à ce moment là elle perd toute
crédibilité
mais voilà un signe qui serait commentée
par les russes et qu'il expliquerait que
avant d'en arriver à la catastrophe
finale eh bien ils doivent prendre
conscience du danger de situation un
dernier mot lna parce que ça aurait un
très rapide on est ce que ça aura un
impact sur la population en tant que le
régime tant que le régime en russie est
en place le mur de la propagande et de
l'opinion est inébranlable ce qui me
fait peur c'est que vladimir poutine ne
peut pas perdre en cette guerre et je ne
vois pas quel narratif il pourrait
mettre en place aujourd'hui pour écrire
une victoire et ça je trouve que c'est
ça qui me fait peur dans le scénario
c'est que parce que s'il perd ça veut
dire que il disparaît et il se sent
fondamentalement menacé aujourd'hui et
c'est là où l'irrationalité est entré en
jeu mais frey ouais merci beaucoup merci
à tous les cas tu remercies elena
volochine merci jean paul palomeros
merci je l'interromps merci antoine aar
jakov ski d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
sur france 24 pour ce débat rester avec
nous l'information continue
[Musique]